[Musique]
bonjour à tous C'est lber Woodson
bonjour c'est Cécile de France bonjour
C'est leilla becti bonjour je suis Eddie
Mitchel mais en vérité là je suis le roi
Louis de quelle partie de la jungle
viens-tu c'est le roi Louis c'est le roi
de la jungle c'est mais il est un peu
contrairement à à celui de du dessin
animé il est un peu plus mafieux il est
un peu plus retor toi petit homme tu
viens du sud parle un peu comme le
parrain voyez c'est tellement inattendu
pour moi de faire Balou excusez-moi qui
peut m'aider Balou est un personnalité
que j'adore il est très subtile il est
très drôle à jouer c'est un chic type
quoi pour moi c'est un rêve qui se
réalise mangli retourne à la caverne
raka passe vraiment par toutes les
palettes c'était très très agréable à
faire un peu de réplique il y a vraiment
plein de choses à jouer je ne le
permettrai pas c'est mon petit nous
sommes la seule famille qu' l' jamais
connu voix de cas du précédent livre de
la jungle était un homme et j'aime
l'idée ce sont les femmes qui sont en
vot tentes je veillerai sur toi j'ai
aimé faire peur qu'avec la voix
serais-tu seul ici je leur referai au
téléphone c'est assez spectaculaire ça
mêle du réel
[Musique]
il y a des images de
synthèse un film de cinéma le scénario
l'action et cetera on est happé le film
est génial incroyable vraiment c'est un
bijou j'ai hâte que vous découvriez le
film sur les écrans le 13 avril au
revoir à très
vite